How big is the moon in the night sky?
The moon seems rather small,
but in reality it really isn't.
Central Europe would easily fit under it.
The surface area of the moon is huge.
To give you some perspective,
it's as big as the whole European
continent. China, the USA, Brazil,
and South Africa together.
Weight-Wise the moon is only about
one 18 month of the massive earth,
but how big is it in relation
to earth? Quite big. Actually.
Our Moon is the biggest in the solar
system and relation to its planet and it's
the fifth largest moon
in the solar system.
Quite a bit bigger than the Dwarf
Planet Pluto. Now, if the mood is ready,
that huge. How far away is it from us
to seem this small in the night sky?
370 kilometers. As far
as the ISS, maybe no.
At that distance,
gravitational forces would rip the
moon apart at 36,000 kilometers.
It would be as far away as
our most distant satellites.
That's adjust the distance to
reality pretty far away, right?
A seven, four, seven would need 28
straight days to fly to the moon.
And even with our current technology,
we'd need two full days
and in a car a lot of time.
So how big is the moon?
Well,
it kind of depends how you define beg,
but seriously though,
it's pretty big.
He Youtube,
we'll try something new this month.
Moon may one video about pool
Boone stuff each Monday in May.
So see you next week.